Lucinda
A ton avis, pourquoi es-tu là ?
Dr Segal dit que le traitement est stable
Pas d'hallucinations, pas de cauchemars
Si tu prends tes médicaments,
alors tu peux partir
Je sais qui je suis,
Je sais ce que je ne suis PAS...
Bienvenue à l'Académie Sword & Cross
Elle n'a aucune idée de qui l'attend
Tu es à la recherche d'un livre ?
Il y en a un, dans une collection spéciale...
Eh, attends !
Tu me rappelles quelqu'un...
J'ai l'impression de te connaitre...
- C'est le cas ?
- Non...
Il te plait beaucoup, non ?
On dirait que tout est relié à Daniel...
Ca ne va pas ?
J'arrête pas d'y penser...
Quelque chose nous lie...
Je t"aime
Quelque chose cloche dans ce groupe...
J'ai trouvé un accès aux dossiers
de tout le monde ici...
J'ai regardé le dossier de Daniel...
C'est vide !
J'ai du mal à croire que ça soit une erreur...
Elle a besoin de notre protection...
Je me souviens de ça
Toute ma vie, on m'a dit que j'étais folle
Voyons-voir si c'est vrai
Comment est-ce possible?
Nous sommes amoureux depuis des millénaires
Tu ne lui as pas dit ?
C'est la malédiction
S'ils tombent amoureux...
Il suffit d'un baiser
Et elle disparaitra.
Embrasse-le et tu mourras
Tu dois respecter l'ordre des choses
Tu ne peux pas faire ce que tu veux
Je me souviens...de tout
La malédiction frappe toujours
quoiqu'on fasse.
Je t'ai choisie
J'ai choisi l'amour